we're joined by former mp rory stewart
who also was uh in cabinet who stood
against boris johnson in the last
conservative leadership election in 2019
uh welcome to you um
but we've had weeks of party gate
haven't we so it's followed us from 2020
in 2021 into 2022 uh far from going away
there are those that are predicting it
could be the downfall of the prime
minister
do you agree what are your thoughts
well i i think it certainly should be
because it should be the last nail in
the coffin because this is a country
which has had one of the worst covert
death rates and one of the poorest
economic performances in the developed
world
in a way it's it's ironic that what
seems to be bringing down the prime
minister is
the downing street party rather than the
record of bad government over the last
year and a half
if you were in his position and uh
were able to make the decision would you
resign
i hope so yes i believe politicians
should resign and i can't see what
future that he has
he may be able to survive for another
few months but he is badly wounded and
essentially in order to
be a leader you need credibility you
need supporters you need energy you need
enthusiasm you need confidence
and those were of course things that
boris johnson had in great great excess
over the last few years and he's lost it
and it's very very difficult to see that
returning and very difficult to see him
being a credible leader again
and what did you make of
christian wakefield crossing the floor
seemingly it might have have backfired
because it seems to have sort of
bolstered uh conservative mps uh with
with tales of some actually withdrawing
letters
i think that's right i think the sense
in any party of party loyalty is very
strong so the rebels that were moving
against boris johnson will have
wanted to feel that they were moving
against boris johnson but not against
the conservative parties so when they
saw one of their colleagues across the
floor that would have taken them aback
but that may in the end turn out not to
be a good thing for the conservative
party because it may just prolong the
very painful last days of boris johnson
and end up damaging the conservative
party brand even more
are you surprised that the prime
minister has got himself into this this
state into this mess
uh not at all um he we should all have
expected this he's been a very famous
public figure for 30 years
the british public has spent 30 years
focusing on the fact that he lies that
he's disorganized that he betrays almost
every personal commitment that he has
he was manifest the unsuited to be prime
minister from the beginning and it's
very very disturbing that a great
country like britain
should have chosen somebody so
unsuitable for the role
and is this about an individual or that
the traits and characteristics that you
describe are they act as well to
describe the conservative party
i think it tells us something about the
system not just the conservative party
the labour party as well it's these are
party systems which have got worse and
worse in britain
because what they're fundamentally about
is winning not running the country so
the the reason people selected boris
johnson
is because they thought he could win a
big majority and the risk is that even
if they would get rid of boris johnson
they will select somebody else purely on
the basis of whether or not they will
win a big majority we need to get beyond
that and we need to start selecting
politicians who are serious who are
credible
and who do jobs responsibly and that
that's a job not just for politicians
that's a job for the media and the
public to make sure that we
vote and support people who are good at
doing their jobs
and today more pressure on the pm with
allegations of blackmail and
intimidation is that something that that
you recognize as methods used by the uh
the parliamentary whip
yes this is all part of the same system
which is that in the end what's been
built are these machines which are about
winning and loyalty
and the whips will do all they can to
try to defend the prime minister and
it's a very ruthless uh often
humiliating process where mps who may
have come from ordinary life they may
have been people who
in previous lives were journalists or
business people or army officers they
end up in parliament and they are
put through this extraordinary hazing
process of which the whips are part of
trying to enforce loyalty to the leader
and this i think is dangerous because it
takes away from the question of people
voting with their consciences and trying
as best they can to work out what's best
for the country and i think that's
happening here again now
you ran against the prime minister to be
leader of the conservative party what
what has been your personal experience
of whips
my experience with whips is that the
british system is very much set up
it's a sort of elective dictatorship a
prime minister comes in doesn't matter
whether it's uh tony blair or gordon
brown or david cameron or theresa may or
boris johnson and the whip's job is to
deliver their will and their manifesto
and they will do it largely by using
promotion one of the problems in british
government is that the reason that
people often become ministers or don't
become ministers is not on the basis of
their
knowledge or their skill at doing a job
it's based on their loyalty whether or
not they do what the whips want now
that's fine for getting the government
business through and there's an argument
for that people want to get government
business through effectively but it does
mean that you end up
with ministers who are often not very
well suited for the jobs that they're
occupying
uh christian wakefield uh the the tory
mp across the floor as we said um
he substantiated the claims by saying he
was threatened and uh with not getting a
secondary school in his constituency i
mean that's that's extremely damning
isn't it
yeah and that's
completely inappropriate
the decisions made by ministers on the
allocation of a secondary school must be
based on genuine need
it is grotesque to suggest that the
government will deprive a constituency
of a secondary school on the basis of
the way that an mp
is voting in the chamber i think that's
not acceptable and i think if this is
happening
there needs to be a very very clear
reinforcement of what should already be
in the ministerial code which is
decisions on that form of investment
must be made objectively on the basis of
need they cannot be
part of some pork barrel politics of
buying political favors
would you expect an investigation now
into these claims that have been made
potentially yes although as we see
whenever these investigations happen
they seem to get stuck in a morass of
ambiguity and equivocation so it's very
very difficult
to see much coming out of these
investigations the end but certainly
this behavior is not good
and british politics would be much
better off if we got beyond these sorts
of behaviors these sorts of games it's
not healthy and look i was it's
difficult for me to talk about these
things obviously i was defeated by boris
johnson leadership elections so i'm
aware when i'm saying these things i may
be saying them partly out of bitterness
and disappointment and i no longer
remember the conservative parties so
maybe you need to take everything that i
say with a pinch of salt but i think the
public as a whole senses that there is
something wrong there's something deeply
wrong with a british political system
and that's not just about boris johnson
that's about all these political games
and in the end it comes down to the fact
that politics is seen too much as a game
and not enough as a real vocation not
enough as
being about running the country well
finally on on the prime minister do you
predict that he will hang on that he
will stay
i think he'll try to hang on as long as
he can but i believe that he is now
fatally wounded as a prime minister it's
almost impossible if you see uh beth
rigby's sky great sky interview with him
you see somebody who has lost the
confidence to lead
and i think it's going to be very
difficult for him to recover from us
let's talk about ukraine and bringing
your experience in the foreign office
have you read president biden suggesting
that the degree to which russia invades
will dictate the response i.e
an incursion being not quite as bad as a
full invasion and therefore the response
not being to that level
well this is unbelievably serious and in
a way as we're distracted by parties in
downing street this issue is much much
bigger
russia is trying to do all it can to
destabilize the west and the united
states
and its move against ukraine is part of
a much much bigger russian move putin
believes that the west is weak he
believes that russia and china's star is
rising
and he is going to do all he can to get
his hands on ukraine and what biden said
was extremely dangerous and entirely
daft it's almost inconceivable
that a leader would say something like
that
the the white house have sought to
clarify his comments uh they said if any
assembled russian units move across the
ukrainian border that is an invasion uh
let there be no doubt at all that if
putin makes his choice russia will pay a
heavy price uh but but but as you say
what what he did say earlier has has
gone out there how will that be
interpreted by vladimir putin is that a
green light to him
putin will see it as further
confirmation of what he believes which
is that there is no real conviction
it's not just president biden he also
will have seen emmanuel macron's
statements where macron is talking about
the eu coming up with its own approach
independent of nato to russia
all of this will convince him that he
can get the best of all worlds he can
threaten to invade he can get a whole
series of concessions and what he's
really going to want to do
is effectively take over ukraine without
having to fight what he wants to do is
to try to bully the west into agreeing
that they won't defend ukraine and then
effectively take power in ukraine
through his proxies and at the moment
unless somebody steps up and unless
there's any real conviction unless we're
actually serious about providing
unfortunately arms to the ukrainian
people we will find ourselves in that
situation
uh and you think seriously that has to
be the the next step to arm the
ukrainian people
yes partly because the only people who
are actually
likely to have the will and the
credibility and resilience to fight the
russians will be the ukrainians
themselves
and therefore probably the only option
remaining i'm very sorry this is the
case right we had many many other
options over the last 10 years but we've
gone through all of them through
weakness and indecision
almost the only options remaining now
are to provide the arms for the
ukrainians to defend themselves
so you hold no hope for remaining talks
i think the talks are a waste of time
putin is not sincere in these talks
right there's no point talking with
somebody who's issued that kind of
ultimatum it's quite clear what putin
wants to do which is to humiliate and
weaken the west
and try to get his hands on ukraine
without fighting
there's no form of concessions which can
be made to putin which are
going to have any realistic positive
result they're just going to weaken our
position further
it's a very uh depressing picture that
you paint so simply that the west sits
and waits for putin to invade
well the actually in all of this britain
is and you know having been rude about
the prime minister i should pay tribute
to the defense secretary britain has
been
more consistent
clearer and more resilient in its
response to russia and ukraine than the
united states and other european
partners but unfortunately britain alone
is nowhere in a position to be able to
fight a russian invasion of ukraine
and i don't think economic sanctions are
going to frighten vladimir putin they
had almost no impact on him when they
were imposed after the invasion of
crimea
so i'm afraid we're back that's 2015. so
i'm afraid we are in a world in which
putin is in a strong position because of
10 years
roy stewart
thank you so much for sharing your views
with us